what we're going to do in this video is
think about how we mult might multiply
592 times 7. and in general we're going
to think about how we would approach
multiplying something that has multiple
digits times something that has one
digit and the way we're going to do it
is the way that if you were to ask your
parents is probably the way that they do
it and so the typical approach is you
would write the larger multi-digit
number on top and then you would write
the smaller single digit number below
that and since it's in the ones place to
seven you would put it in the ones place
column so you'd put it right below the
ones place in
right in the larger number so right
below that 2 and then you write the
multiplication symbol
and the way you think about it is all
right i'm just going to take each of
these places and multiply it by the 7.
so for example if i'm taking those two
ones and i'm multiplying it times seven
well that's going to be 14 ones well
like there's no digit for 14. i can only
put four of those ones over here and
then the other 10 ones i can express as
1 10 and so i'd put it up there
sometimes when people learn it they say
hey 2 times 7 is 14 i write the 4 and i
carry the 1. but all you're doing is
you're saying hey 14 is 110 plus 4 ones
but then you move over to the tens place
you say hey what's nine tens times seven
well nine times seven is sixty-three so
nine tens times seven is sixty-three
tens plus another ten is sixty-four tens
you can only put four of those tens over
here so the other 60 tens you can
express as 600s so you can stick that
right over there now a lot of people
would explain that as saying hey 9 times
7 is 63 plus 1 is 64. write the 4 and
carry the 6 but hopefully you understand
what we mean by carrying you're really
trying to write 64 tens
only 4 of those 10s can be expressed
over here or that's maybe the cleanest
way to do it and then the other 60 tens
you can express as six hundreds and then
last but not least five hundreds times
seven
is going to be 35 hundreds and then you
plus
then you add 600 you get
hundreds
so 4100 so it's 4144.
now i want to reconcile this or connect
it to with other ways that you might
have seen this
so let's say that let's do this again so
if we were to write 592
times 7.
so one way that we've approached in the
past is we say all right what's 2 times
7 well that's going to be 14. notice
that's the same 14 we're just
representing it a little bit differently
then we might say well what is 9 times 7
do the same color
and it's really 9 10s times 7 that's 63
tens so you might write it right over
there which is the same thing as 630 and
then you could think about what is 5
hundreds times 7 well that's 35 hundreds
so you could write it like that same
thing as three thousand five hundred and
then you would add everything up
so you have a total of four ones you
have a total of four tens you have a
total of eleven hundreds so you could
write one hundred there and then regroup
the other 10 hundreds into the thousands
place is 1000 1000 plus 3 thousands is 4
000. so we got the exact same answer
because we essentially did the same
thing over here when we were carrying it
we were essentially regrouping things
from here and you could you could think
about it where we're condensing our
writing versus what we did here here we
just very systematically said 2 times 7
9 times 7 5 times 7 but we made sure to
keep track of the places to figure out
what each of those you could think of as
partial products would be
and then we added well here we carried
along the way essentially regrouping the
values when we said hey two ones times
seven ones that's fourteen ones which is
the same thing as four ones plus one ten
and so on and so forth so i encourage
you one it's good to learn this method
it's the most common way that folks
multiply once again your parents
probably learned it this way but it's
really valuable to understand why these
two things are the same thing so really
ponder that think about that and see if
you can if it all makes sense what's
going on that you're not just blindly
memorizing the steps